ما هي المراه
هذا عنوان فيلم مدته 95 دقيقه وقالب
العالم وخصوصا على تويتر الفيلم نزل فيه
20 22 لكن على تويتر الشركه المنتجه له
والمنصه الاعلاميه المحافظه ديلي واير
نزلته من ثلاثه ايام وقالت انها تبغى الكل
يكون عنده فرصه يشوف الفيلم مجانا لمده 24
ساعه الفيلم كما هو واضح من اسمه بناقش
تعريف المراه موضوع بيبان بديهي وبسيط لكن
للاسف مؤخرا وبسبب تحرك اليساريين
المتطرفين المعروفين باصحاب ثقافه الوك
صار موضوع شائك وصعب
راضي
[موسيقى]
الفيلم من تقديم وانتاج ماتورش المؤلف
والمقدم المحافظ واللي محول هذا الموضوع
لقضيه حياته ايش الموضوع الموضوع انه كثير
من اليساريين والمتطرفين ومع تصاعد الحديث
عن حقوق الاقليات صاروا بينادوا انه من حق
اي احد يعرف عن نفسه بالجنس اللي بغاه
يعني يجي رجل حابب يعرف عن نفسه انه امراه
فيعتبروا انه هذا الموضوع من حقه ولازم
نتعامل معاه على هذا الاساس والموضوع زاد
لدرجه صار بيغيروا في المناهج وفي اللغه
يعني بيقولوا انه ما نقول نساء حوامل بل
نقول اشخاص حوامل وانه ما نقول الستات
اللي بتجيهم الدوره الشهريه بل الاشخاص
اللي بتجيهم الدوره الشهريه شايفين يعني
انه في ناس بيولوجيين شيء لكن بيختاروا
انهم يعرفوا عن نفسهم بجنس اخر الفيلم
بيعارض الفكره وبيتحطها بقوه وبيقول علميا
ما هي المراه وانه اي شيء ثاني ما اسمه
امراه الفيلم عليه اكثر من 170 مليون
مشاهده على تويتر في ثلاثه ايام وتقريبا
200 الف رتويت ونصف مليون لايك
موضوع الفيلم مثل ما قلنا الشائك وحساس
ومتحول لملف سياسي اساسي يعني صاير شعار
من شعارات الاحزاب والفرقاء السياسيين وفي
بلد مثل امريكا مثلا هو الان ملف اساسي
على طاوله الانتخابات المقبله فعندنا
بايدن الديمقراطي اللي بيدعم حق كل شخص
انه يعرف عن جنسه مثل ما هو يبغى في
مرشحين مثلا مثل عن الحزب الجمهوري اللي
بيوعد بانه يوقف الوك عند حدهم وحتى زوجته
من كم يوم طلعت لابسه جاكيت بيحاربهم علنا
وصراحه الجاكيت عليه خريطه فلوريدا اللي
هي الولايه اللي زوجها حاكمها ومكتوب
عليها هنا سيموت الوق
وفي وقت الاصوات الديمقراطيه في العالم
وتحديدا والاعلام الغربي بتدعم الوقحه كل
شخص يعرف عن نفسه مثل ما يبغى بدات تطلع
الاصوات المحاربه للفكره مثل ما قلنا
ديصانتيس مثلا مثال عليهم الى الماسك
برزقه واحد من اهم الاصوات المؤثره في
محاربه هذه الثقافه
اللي سبق و هاجم تطرف الليبراليين اعاد
تغريد الفيلم وعلق عليهم انه كل الاهالي
اللازم يشوفوا الفيلم وقال انه انا مع انه
البالغين الموافقين حرين يعملوا اللي
يبغوه عشان يكونوا سعداء لكن بدون ما
ياذوا الاخرين لكن الاطفال ما عندهم
القدره يوافقوا او لا وعلشان كذا لازم
يكون في قوانين تحميهم طبعا تغريده ماسك
حولت الوثائقي وجذبت الملايين
لمشاهدته ماسك الزمان لمنهاجم الووكر
يهاجم فكره انه تويتر بي افكارهم وارائهم
بس وعرض امثله حيه على هذا الشيء ووعد انه
تويتر راح يعرض كل الاراء ويبدو انه عرض
هذا الفيلم اول خطوه كيف تويتر من بعد ما
كان عامل اتفاق مع صناع الفيلم للترويج له
وعرضه على المنصه لمده 24 ساعه مجانا رجع
لغى العقد معهم وقالوا انه السبب انه
الفيلم فيه حالتين ان وصف فيهم اشخاص بجنس
غير اللي بيعرفوا عن نفسهم فيه ماسك لما
شاف كلام صناع الفيلم عن الموضوع رد عليهم
وقال لهم اللي صار خطا من بعض العاملين في
تويتر والموضوع طبعا مسموح وقال ماسك انه
استعمال ضمائر مخالفه للضمائر لشخص بيفضل
يتنادى فيها هو وقاحه دون شك لكنه ليس
قانوني من الاخر بيقول لهم ما في قانون
بيقول انه اذا ناديت احد بغير الضمير اللي
بيستخدمه يعني من الاخر غير الجنس اللي
بيعرف عن نفسه فيه
قانوني عادي يعني وسامح ماسك بالترويج
للفيلم على تويتر عشان كل اللي قلناه
سابقا هذا بنقول اليوم انه تعريف المراه
تحول لصراع سياسي وفي وقت في ناس مع انه
كل واحد بيعرف عن نفسه مثل ما يبغى في ناس
شايفه انه جنون وتطرف في الديمقراطيه وانه
في اشياء ما بتخضع للقهواء والاراء
الشخصيه في علم في بيولوجيا في حقائق غير
قابله للتغيير طبعا هنا لازم ننوه
مشاهدينا انه نحن ما بنتكلم ابدا عن اللي
عندهم مرض او اضطراب والطب يستدعي تحولهم
نحن بنتكلم هنا عن اللي بيعرفوا عن نفسهم
من غير جنسهم بس لانهم حاسين بهذا الشيء
ويبغوا الكل يتعامل معاهم على هذا الاساس
ويوافقوهم طيب نحن معانا من لندن الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد عجاج اهلا
فيك معانا دكتور احمد اول شيء خليني ابتدي
معاك من مصطلح الووك اصلا البدايه بدايه
هذا المصطلح ما كان كيف ما صار الان
يستخدم ايش اللي طرق على التعريف بحيث
وصلنا الان لهذا النوع او لهذا التعريف
طبعا هو التطور التاريخي بهذا الامر عندما
بدا كان مساله تتعلق بالحقوق عامه وحريات
اساسيه لكن مع الوقت يعني تطورت هذه
الحقوق واصبحت تاخذ فروع كثيره واصبح
الهدف هو ان الانسان هو الذي يصنع الحقوق
والانسان هو محور الحقوق ذاته وتحول اكثر
الى اصبح ان شعور الانسان هو الذي يحدد
هويته وانه يجب ان نعترف بذلك بعباره اخرى
اصبح يعني مفهوم الرب خارج المعادله وهناك
مفهوم الانسان الذي يضع القوانين ومن هنا
انفصل المحافظون عن الليبراليون او الوقت
المتطرفون لكن حتى انفسهم الان مختلفون مع
بعضهم حول هذا الموضوع حول ان الانسان
بوسعي ان يعرف نفسه رجلا او امراه فقط
مجرد انه يشعر انه امراه لانه كما نعرف ان
القوانين ناخذ بريطانيا مثلا يمكن للانسان
ان يشعر انه امراه ويذهب الى طبيب نفسه
ويتحقق منه ويستمع اليه ثم بعد ذلك يوافقه
ويذهب الى العمليه ويغير عمليه الهرمون او
ربما يتخلص من اعضائه التناسليه هذا
القانون يعطيه شهاده يقول انه الان لم يعد
رجلا اصبح امراه لكن مجرد ان يقول الانسان
والله انا اشعر اني امراه وهو رجل
وبالتالي يجب ان تعاملوني كذلك هذا هو
التمدد الليبرالي الخطير الذي يهدد
المجتمع لانه من هذا المنطلق هؤلاء ينادون
ان هذه الحريات حق مطلق وبالتالي يجب ان
تدرس كما تدرس الحريات الاخرى الطفل يجب
ان يعرف انه اذا شعر انه امراه او انه شعر
انه بنت فيجب ان نقبل بذلك ونقول له هذا
شيء جيد لانه هو شعورك ويجب ان نتعامل معه
وبذلك المساله لم تعد معرفيه بمعنى ما هي
الصفات البيولوجيه والحقيقيه للمراه بل
اصبحت هوائيه هي مزاج الشخص ونحن نعرف
ايضا من الاحصائيات ان 60 90% من الاطفال
يغيرون يعني ميولهم هذه عند وصول صل
البلوغ وبالتالي الخطوره تكمن الان بما
يطالب به الواقع انهم يريدون التعليم
الناشئه ان ذلك شيء طبيعي جدا وهذا خطير
جدا لان ذلك القيم التقليديه كلها ستنهار
وسينشى نظام اخلاقي جديد خطير جدا هذا
الموضوع كيف تحول الان الى جزء يعني لجزء
من الصراع السياسي يعني الناس صايره ممكن
تنتخب على اساس موقف الشخص من هذا الموضوع
طبعا يعني في النظام الديمقراطي الناس
تختلف على كثير من الامور والسياسيون
بطبيعتهم يريدون ان يعني طبعا بعضهم
مبدئيون يدخلون السياسه لقناعات تامه
بانهم يدافعون عن اشياء يؤمنون بها وبعضهم
الاخر يميلون الى استخدام هذه الخلافات
وحصد النتائج من خلالها وبذلك تحول الخلاف
من خلاف يعني قانوني يتناقش في المجتمع
لانه حتى الان ليس كل الدول تعترف به تحول
الى يعني حلبه سياسيه كما تفضلت وشرحت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بين محافظين
يتزعمهم الرئيس ترامب وبين الليبراليين
يتزعمهم الرئيس بايدن وبالتالي كلاهما
يستفيد من هذه الظاهره لكن
ستؤدي في النهايه الى انقسام اكبر في
المجتمع والى يعني خطوره اكبر وتداعياتها
او تبعاتها ستصبح اكثر فاكثر لذلك يجب
النظر اليها من نظره موضوعيه وعلميه
تحل هذه الاشكاليه لانه لانه لا يمكن لشخص
لنفترض انه في بريطانيا في امريكا اصدر
ورقه بانه امراه وذهب الى بلد اخر لا
يعترف بذلك فكيف يمكن التعامل معه هذه
امور خطيره او انه قال انا امراه ودخل الى
الارحاض النساء وهو رجل بكامل صفاته
الجنسيه يعني هذه مساله معقده جدا
والتعامل معها بناحيه سياسيه فقط دون
الولوج الى تداعياتها القانونيه الاخلاقيه
امر خطير جدا وحده يمكن من الاشياء كمان
المخيفه في هذا الموضوع زي ما ذكرت دكتور
احمد هي انه في سيطره من خلينا نقول
المؤيدين لهذه الفكره على كثير من
المؤسسات الكبيره فيتم الترويج لها لولا
الان انه ايلون ماسك مسك تويتر وسمح لهذا
الراي الاخر انه يظهر ما كنا حنشوف كثير
من هذه الاشياء نحن بنضطر نلجا لبودكاست
واشياء معينه عشان نسمع الراي الاخر يعني
صار في فرض لراي الوك او المدافعين عنه
برايك هذا يعني انه على كم سنه الجايه
حنشوف خلاص انتصار تام لهذه الرؤيه
طبعا يعني هنا يعني المفارقه الشديده ان
الواك يؤمنون ايمان قطعي بحريه التعبير
وان الانسان ان ينتقد وياخذ يعني ما يريد
من اعتراضات لكنهم بداوا في النهايه
تحولون الى استبدااديين يرفضون الراي
المعارض ويجرون الناس الى المحاكم تحت
شعار الحريات هم اساسا جاؤوا من اجل حفظ
الحريات واعطاء الناس حق التعبير
والمعارضه والتظاهر والان هم لا يريدون
ذلك وهنا الخطوره لانه هناك بعض الدعاوى
قدمت ضد بعض الاشخاص في بريطانيا مثلا
عندما قالوا
احدى الموظفات ووضعت يعني في الفيسبوك وفي
تويتر مقالات تقول لها انها لا تؤمن بان
الرجل يمكن ان يصبح امراه وبالتالي احد
الزملاء لها اشتكى من ذلك واعتبرها انها
ذلك يعني فوبيا للجنس ولذلك دخلت الى
المحكمه خلت فيه مشاكل كثيره هذا امر خطير
جدا ويضرب مصداقيه الواق بانهم اساسا هم
اصحاب الحريات وينادون بالحريات وان كل
شيء مفتوح للنقاش لكنهم الان يريدون فرد
رؤيتهم ومن يخالفهم يجرونه الى المحاكم
ويريدون اكثر تعميم هذه الثقافه عن طريق
استخدام الدوله بمعنى خطير جدا اي ان
الدوله تصبح في الديمقراطيه دوله
استبداديه تفرض رايها على الاخرين
المعارضين وعلى سيره الانتخابات الامريكيه
دكتور احمد عجاج نائب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق مايك بنز قدم الان اوراق ترشحه
رسميا
للرئاسه الامريكيه
فهنشوف رايه هو كمان في موضوع علوك وحنشوف
كيف حتحتدم المعركه واضح انه في كثير ناس
صاروا ميالين كمان لديسانس لانه جديد في
موضوع الوك مثلا ايلون ماسك كثير زي كذا
ففي اصبحت فعلا فاصل يعني هذا الموضوع بين
الناس يعني
صحيح فنحن صحيح جدا يعني
انا حابه بس لانه للاسف دعمنا الوقت فانا
بشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد عجاج شكرا
لك